entre le maillot une pièce au nombre moi
je suis pour
pourquoi pour le maillot c'est ce qu'on
sait c'est tout à fait normal je suis
pas pourquoi je suis content évidemment
mais vous savez pourquoi
qu'est ce que c'est indécent malgré tout
1 et vous entendre avant oui ça d'accord
ça je suis pour qu'on sait au moins
pensé oh moi c'est qu'on a devant soi
quoi pour le noyau il est pas mal quoi
enfin pour des plages comme la baule
c'est un peu cru pour la liberté chacun
est libre de faire leurs temps au
registre est plutôt contre voyez vous
parce que quand même une certaine
esthétique qui manque les couleurs et
tout ça non je suis tout à fait contre
pour support pour les filles sont bien
quand ça leur va
pour ou contre le maillot de bain
inquiète
c'est pas ça dépend des femmes qui
n'abandonnait jamais vu à l'appui cela
va me faire une opinion avant de voir
bon je suis pour
pour mille à l'heure où certaines
limites quand même lesquels à ceux qui
n'ont qu'à pas de par le porter et qui
sont bien je suis pour
pour regarder les gens inscrits mais
j'aurai une fiancée je voudrais pas je
suis en beauté
je suis contre la main pourquoi parce
que j'estime que c'est d'aller sa
rencontre
pourquoi moi pour la couleur pour
commencer un promener les seins à l'air
sur une plage bat pas que c'est quand
même
je suis pour pour la plus je suis
content pour ma femme tout au moins mais
pour les autres ça dépendrait pourquoi
pourquoi je suis content
et bien parce que je pense que la
plupart de ceux qui s'exhibe ray avec ce
maillot là ne serait peut-être pas les
plus bas la foire à moi c'est pour ça me
plairait pas mais enfin quand même à aa
la paix il s'agirait mesdemoiselles et
vous pour contre le maillot une pièce
pourquoi
ce que je sais les temps je crois que
toutes les filles qui auront une jolie
voix tricks dans leur for intérieur sont
vos journaux ce compte pourquoi qui
c'est ridicule pour une pièce pourquoi
est-ce qu avatar ce qu'elle est je
trouve que c'est mieux
la femme est bien plus chic dans un
maillot une pièce
qu'est ce
et pas le 201 pour pourquoi une pièce
oui j'ai beau pourquoi parce que ces
préconise t on doit décoller son nom
c'était génial c'est irrespectueux pour
la personne elle même et pour les autres
à dire sa finition
même si c'est très jolie musique montre
le maillot une pièce
pourquoi parce qu'il est de lui-même il
est déjà pas très joli je suis contre un
maillot une pièce pour moi parce que
c'est gênant mais beaucoup d'élèves et
de pièces non mais pourquoi parce que je
pense qu'il faut être deux peut-être que
si j'étais jeune et puis c'était bien
fait évidemment pourquoi pourquoi a
changé
on veut vraiment pourquoi
bonjour madame windows renseignements du
prix des deux maillots s'il vous plaît
faut-il prendre 66 francs est ce que
vous vendez le deux pièces moins une
comment le voulait mourir en pas du tout
leurs deux noms moment d'ailleurs
écouter ce n'est pas votre cas vous ne
riez pas de charme avec à bon et vous
n'avez pas l'impression que ça prendra à
la boule arrêté mais l'embellie sur la
fraîche avec mode remarqué ce soit les
deux pièces devine d'ailleurs cette
belle bon voilà vous avez des enfants
cela non non non voyons pas de moratoire
d'en avoir voir invitation que m'avait
même pas là monde
c'est l'adjoint comment réagit la
municipalité de la baule à cette mode du
dossier est moins une c'est une question
d'actualité
elle a déjà été posée et je vais vous
répondre
son prendre la paternité de la réponse
qui a été fait quelqu'un avait posé la
question à l'entourage de monsieur le
maire et il a été répondu d'une façon
presque rythme il certain qu'en
l'occurrence de sénateur maire ne
saurait ferme et lisible